so two words often get uh thrown around
and confused for one another and i
thought we would take
a few minutes to clarify the differences
between salts
and sodium
now we know they're related
but
i wanted to get exactly what the
differences are and how to kind of uh
make sense of all the different numbers
i hear around how much i'm supposed to
get every day so
i always think for salt of my salt
shaker at home it sits right next to my
pepper shaker
and whenever i have dinner i often reach
for it
and sometimes i think you know am i
eating too much of it or am i
putting on more than i should and so i
was thinking about this in terms of a
spoon so if you have a spoon let's say a
teaspoon
of salt
and let's say i took this teaspoon of
salt
here it is
and i weighed it on a scale
i would find that one teaspoon of salt
weighs about six grams let me write that
here so it's about six grams
and 6 grams is the same as 6 000
milligrams
so that's the weight of one teaspoon of
salt
now the question comes up how much of
that is from sodium
so to answer that we know that sodium
chloride nacl
is salt that is what salt is made of and
if i imagine there's nothing in my salt
shaker except for sodium chloride no no
uh
ants have gotten in there you know no
other uh
stuff
besides the sodium chloride then i can
assume that all six thousand milligrams
of salt is going to be either from the
sodium or from the chloride okay
now the n a just to be totally clear is
the sodium part
and the cl is the chloride part that's
what that means
and
they actually all atoms have a certain
atom atomic mass unit so you can
actually weigh
the the atoms and line them up by size
and you know which is the the largest in
weight and which is the smallest in
weight and sodium weighs out at about 23
units
and chloride is about 35 units
so this is chloride right here and this
is sodium right here and so if i was to
sum it up i would get 23 plus 35 is 58
units and units just
to say it again or to write it out
rather is atomic mass units
so now that i have the total atomic mass
units
i can try to figure out what
proportion is from the sodium and what
proportion is from the chloride so
for the first part the sodium
i can simply take the 23
units over the 58 unit total and the
units cancel out and that works out to
about 40 percent
so that means about 40 of the weight of
salt is actually coming from the sodium
part
and the chloride part is the rest of it
so i've got 35 units over 58 units and
that is about 60 percent and again the
units cancel out 60
so i know that in salt 40 percent of the
weight is coming from the sodium 60 from
the chloride got it
now
i have to go back to my teaspoon in my
teaspoon i had 6 grams or 6 000
milligrams
so in that teaspoon
i can just multiply it by these numbers
to figure out how much of the weight
comes from the sodium and how much comes
from the chloride so the sodium
gives me 40 of 6000
which when you multiply those two
numbers you get 2400
milligrams
of sodium
and 60 times 6000 is 3600
milligrams of chloride so now i know in
each teaspoon i have 2400 milligrams of
sodium
and now i've actually looked and i've
seen that there are recommendations on
how much sodium you should get in your
diet if you're not having any medical
problems in general so i will call that
a normal
daily salt amount or normal
amount
and this is a
regular this would be a regular amount
of salt
and then there's like a low salt amount
so this would be like a low
salt amount so if you're on a low salt
diet we'll figure out how much salt
you're supposed to take in or how much
sodium you're supposed to take in
and same for regular how much you should
be taking if you're on a regular diet
and i'm going to do it both from a salt
perspective and also from a sodium
perspective so let's do the sodium
perspective first so normal amount you
should get actually let me write per day
and let's do
sodium
and over here we'll do salt
so
regular amount of sodium you should get
per day
uh is about
2300 milligrams
so 2300 milligrams
and
on a low salt diet you should get about
1500 milligrams
now we know
that one teaspoon has 2400 milligrams
and 24 and 2300 i think are pretty close
so in my conversion i'm going to assume
that that means i can have about
one teaspoon per day
of salt
and on a low salt diet you're
recommended to have no more than about
1500 milligrams of sodium
and if one teaspoon equals 2400
milligrams of sodium
then 1500 is about two-thirds of it so
that's about two-thirds of a teaspoon of
salt
so when i look at a teaspoon of salt now
i just remember that if this is my
teaspoon
that if i'm on a regular diet i can
basically take one of them each day not
each meal but each day
and if i'm on a low salt diet i can only
fill it up about two-thirds of the way
and i'd have to stop there because
that's the limit of sodium that i'm
recommended